quand je vois les gens qui sont perçus
d'aller au paradis ça me fout un peu les
glandes
tous ces gens bien pensant bien honnêtes
propres ça ça va être terrible
tu sais qu'on fait c'est quand pour la
dernière fois oh mais tu t'es confessé
déjà oui parce que
sinon ça te faisait du bien
tu peux dire parce qu'on sortait très
léger c'était un truc comme après après
résultat d'analyse quoi
la même sensation merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dis-moi j'ai été dur à vivre pendant
tout ce temps d'être le beauf de service
j'ai joué des personnages qui étaient un
petit peu caricaturaux
une tête de français c'est vrai que
j'avais une tête de France
que je m'étais fait pousser pendant le
service militaire c'était pour passer
inaperçu puis maintenant je passais plus
du tout une aperçu ça te fait souffrir
de te voir en franchoueur à l'heure tous
les soirs dans les arènes de l'info sur
Canal+
c'est vrai que c'est une image c'est une
caricature d'une image qui était déjà
une caricature quand moi je devais c'est
le look le pénis qui tient
et avant des pougets de pénis c'est plus
grave
ça s'est passé comment le jour où tu as
rasé ta moustache
le succès l'argent que tu vas
aujourd'hui ou être le sosie de Thierry
Lhermitte par exemple
comme ça
si tu devais être incarner tu préfères
être incarné en Woody Allen où on a l'un
de l'autre
je sais pas bien mais ce qui me terrifie
c'est que quand je vois les gens qui
sont persuadés au Paradis ça me fout un
peu les langues
tous ces gens bien pensant bien honnêtes
propres ça ça va être terrible en fait
les gens que j'apprécie
quand on va plutôt en enfer donc
si tu devais mourir ton petit Arthur ça
vient une seule chose à lui dire ça
serait quoi
pas trop de tristesse
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu